[Musique]
gtp invite par exemple je serai un
tournevis et bravo tu t'étais un défaut
labonté c'était une injure camarades
ouais c'était un collabo
embrasser diack
et c'était d une cicatrice
un bleu à l'âme c'était un dictateur mi
temps
c'était une injure
une rigolote sur et tête de noeud
maladie une maladie je fais ce pôle
parkinson ou un truc comme ça quand même
ouais un microbe
[Musique]
sur une grippe une grippe quelconque et
show-man comme un reptile un reptile
ainsi re fois à lunettes
pourquoi poser lunettes ça sympa les
serpents noire ou blanche c'est comme si
tu étais une infirmité
c'est dur je serai pas aveugle va
peut-être muette
si tu étais un assassin tu serais qui
comme assassa jack l'éventreur on en
parle encore un vice à la vertu
une guerre
un petit conflit de rien du tout c
dans entre deux tribus africaines un
supplice
on en a plus inventer que deux positions
pour baiser quand celle difficile le
choix
alors je dirais la roue peut-être faits
atroces cette fois c'est le pire selon
vous laissera pas de quoi c'est quand on
suspend le mec au dessus d'une corde
j'ai pas dit m et puis on laisse tomber
la corne alors ils tombent au sol et en
remonte et on laisse tomber indéfiniment
puis ce que fait nicolas hulot tous les
samedis dans ushuaïa quoi lui ce point
un élastique si peu guermantes boussole
c'est pour ça un accident
s'accorde un casque un accident j'ai pas
un de la route
un quotidien et si tu étais une
cicatrice elle sera ou sous l'aisselle
gauche probablement réunit deux fois par
oui nous sort que ça le cicatrices n'y a
pas besoin de frimer avec les plus
belles sont intérieures ouais ça fait un
peu attention bien ça mais
je crois que tout le monde en est plein
mais on les voit pas tout
je te dis si tu étais un défaut du srec
elle défaut la différence si tu étais
une injure
[Musique]
allez vous faire [ __ ] si tu étais une
maladie
pire que les sida est ce possible oui
d'ailleurs au fait c'est parce que c'est
à cause du sida tu crois qu'elle se
refuse à lui
rennes de l'homme sait bien qu'il ya une
sorte de peur générale well as qui
redistribue toutes les cartes et que ça
va être très intéressant pour les vrais
professionnels de jouer de cette peur
ambiante
si tu es tellement des vampires nouveau
sans valeur s'il était un microbe
[Applaudissements]
celui de la vie un insecte 1,5 le
scarabée immortel un reptile
là le serpent de la genèse c'était un
vis à vis la notion même de vis si tu
étais un supplice un supplice toujours
la chose privée qu'ils se seraient de
bons à laquelle personne
un supplice auquel personne n'aurait
d'accès un supplice active oui tout à
fait un supplice moral moral si tu étais
un supplice tu seras un supplice morale
un supplice morale qui va au fond des
choses et un accident un accident
[Musique]
la vie est un accident si tu étais un
défaut du srec elle défaut mangeurs de
gâteaux site était une injure
charognards j étais maladie isolement
c'était un insecte
ce serait une mouche pourquoi
parce que des mouches pas empêché de
travailler quand j'écrivais et que le
mouche son opiniâtre reviennent toujours
se mettre à faire de faux pas c'est
infernal
une mouche ne vous empêche de faire la
sieste un mot je peux t'empêcher de
faire un livre
si tu étais un assassin je serai soit
bernard henri lévy soit philippe soler
soit jean edern hallier je tuerai
l'esprit c'était une arme
ce serait une arme blanche très aiguisé
comme les crayons je taime crayon tous
les soirs vous en avez une couche et ça
m'étonne pas
si tu étais un poison je serai critique
littéraire est un collabo
je serai français tu vois qu'il est bien
ce jeu et si tu étais un supplice tu
serais quel supplice libre je serai
directeur de rubrique littéraire dans un
grand magazine
et si j'étais un accident pour finir je
continuerai à écrire
c'était une injure une injure
allez vous faire [ __ ] à à celle là
même que salers exactement pareil
j'étais à microbes
c'est pas l'arrivisme wayne cet été un
poison le cyanure pour un suicidaire
comme moi ça c'est un collabo 3 bat et
rebattus car j'admire beaucoup les deux
étendards quittant descend d'un des plus
grands romans français du xxème siècle
un dictateur néron nero pourtant tu
connais bien les philippines quand même
passer du temps tu arrivé à défiler dans
les tribunes de mal à marcos mais marcos
ne peut arrêter un producteur normaux
comme c'était un très bon démocrate
marcoux c'est un grand calomnie à 10 par
mois je regrette marcos c'était un homme
extrêmement les marins qui n'est aussi
qu'il fallait quelqu'un de charmant mais
marcos avait un peu plus de branches
ouais marco c'était un n'est pas si
mauvais comme un vulgaire ce que les
gens qui en parlent et animale
marcos marcos mais marcos café dictateur
non moi je reste un héros un vrai
service
je dirais le vent évident pour moi ça
serait d'abstinence ou alors on pourrait
dire l'ivrognerie parce que j'adore le
bon vin si tu étais un nazi c'est quoi
comme nazi elle est belle la vie si
j'aurais dit n'est encore un livre de
moi c'était une infirmité
[Musique]
c'est quoi une sincérité l'objectivité
du souhait
je suis déjà aveugle je vais avoir les c
qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans ce bas monde et isole ses pairs
et si tu as été un poison ciguë si du
tout de suite tu penses à ça des fois
non
ah bon
pas trop ah bon j'ai pas d'argent elle à
hemingway la seule arme que tu es chez
toi c'est une seringue quoi et comme tu
la mets sur la table on pense pas que le
cancer vraiment pas je sais m'a été
donnée par le père de jane carrey la
dernière seuls les officiers blessés
avaient droit à cette prime dans poule 2
en film et et deviennent pompey doit
figurer souffrent 15 ans c'est vraiment
fou et british et offre tout ça oui
perfide albion est un accident vous
était arrivé bien le hindenburg là le
truc nazis qui s'est scratché sur new
york
c'est du rap avant la venue des sites
étaient une cicatrice elle tend à
voilà
c'est un échec pour y arriver
lt wazemmes
c'est dans le métier
juste il faut que je prenne way
maintenant j'ai eu beau tu as beaucoup
de blé cela me disais que c'est beaucoup
de blessés one of our way je pense que
j'ai rangé et parfois je suis au rouge
non
wen a renseigné un des derniers grands
c'est fermé du 19 sec tout dans les
autres à lyon ou encore voir les jets
privés
c'était bien mais finalement j'ai pas
fini
ah oui encore quelques bons coups
avec bambou du marais avec lui foute de
claques dans la gueule c'est pas un jury
s'est fait un shampoing avec jean galmot
assez bien le fils de son père
[Musique]
si tu étais un défaut du serait quoi
j'étais un défaut ouais l'envi qu'une
envie aller assouvi un feuilleton envie
là ça va non pas encore je vais très
très star une injure ça je sais pas quel
peuple
un cadavre d'injures six membres en un
jour c'est celle de nietzsche qui sait
donner à l'autre la honte de soi c'est
la pire chose tu le fais deux fois quand
tu servait à saint tropez de l'est entre
deux toits ces sacs pour ça que tu leur
emploi et barclays et nettoyer ses
chemises tachées à la mousse au chocolat
ses terres et puis je compense la prime
fils et issac c'est important c'était
une infirmité
j'étais une infirmité autres incapable
les médiations un assassin tige est un
assassin peut-être landru parce qu'il
aimait vraiment les flammes et une
guerre
les guerres 17 la guerre des sexes
je passe bien quoi
c'est toujours avec cette fille qui
s'appelle marie quitte équilibre ouais
tu vas rester longtemps dû qu'à toi
petit à petit tu as trouvé ton chez toi
tu as trouvé ton verdure à trouver mari
ça va s'arranger
s'il était une arme à double tranchant
[Musique]
je serai une maladie elle cancer dans un
bon cancer généralisé mais encore que le
pari reste des régions penser qu'il ya
une façon de faire la sécurité sociale à
la carte
on parie sur deux camps on mourra et si
on gagne on est remboursé le triple le
latéral ça peut rapporter gros
le concert on sait jamais il ya une
maladie cardiovasculaire ou le cancer
voilà les français le sida il pas une
forme du chrtr donc non mis en adoption
voiture étant une troisième donc tu
paries récupérait en soutien de ce que
tu as décidé plus ou moins cher et les
autres frais remboursés mais c'est un
truc qui était au centre d'un cancer et
si tu étais un microbe
c'est un petit microbes mikron toutes
les microbes à champignons et truffe
invités terrain vis à vis la
masturbation strictement c'est ce que tu
préférais c'est ce qui reste
ouais moi tout le monde s'en va cet été
une guerre une guerre non un mouvement
un mouvement
un guerrier ou en soutenant la révolte
du ghetto de varsovie je trouve assez
exaltant bien oui le seul truc fait
chaque fois que les civils casse la
gueule aux militaires et varsovie ton
père oui oui mais c'est la vie ça n'a
rien à voir si simplement que j'aime pas
trop les militaires l'accident un
accident ouais pas une essence très
bonne réponse une cicatrice non je
dirais pas et d'albert vous voulez la
voir et 1h06 gavage et elles sont là
toutes façons de faire les fesses tout
enfin les chapeaux téléphone des cités
d'un terroriste pour finir en beauté un
terroriste en fin bouillon je suis pas
tort
pas du tout non je ne vois pas comment
c'est la merde quand même
non non je fous la merde [ __ ] la merde
dans la dans le fumier la miellée frêche
non non je m'interroge
[Musique]
c'est étaient une injure je repère un
coaching gtt une maladie
o'shea cancer de la gorge concernant le
prêt dégueulasse parler bien partir et
si tu étais un vie ce sujet tous les
chasseurs
branche retraités des deux satellites et
une arme je coiffe la planète s'est
jamais tué quelqu'un jusqu'à maintenant
je le saurais si tu replonger bien un
jour je sais pas il ya un mec je vous en
manque
j'aurais pu le faire quand j'étais
c'était vraiment accro tu aurais pu
faire il faut pas grand chose pour pas
grand chose
un poison merci
derrière la drogue accident personne ça
a le goût salé l'odeur
ray de l'hérault ne s'est pas de danse
un supplice je parle
et si tu étais un accident avec des
choses très violent crash en avion
le prévenu lors d'explosions alerte un
flash ou 9h02
[Musique]
c'est un défaut par exemple si j'étais
un défaut intolérants l'injure rbe est
content c'était un assassin j'étais un
assassin
e
mais ce n'est ce pas pourquoi ce qu'il
est intelligent tu t'étais un accident
j'étais un accident un accident dans une
porsche spyder sur la route de salinas
une cicatrice
une cicatrice là comme sylvie vartan
c'est une perversion
remerciant eux
la zoophilie ya que moi qui ai parlé au
chili d'habitude pourquoi j'aime
tellement les animaux que à bord du coup
c'est d'éviter de témoigner parle de ce
genre de trucs voilà on est 2 mais j'ai
trouvé mon maître alors et mais quel
animal peut pas faire réagir les
schaffhousois gros le seul fils en effet
la haye
le petit jaguar à bord karine plus beaux
doit essayer je sais pas mais si j'étais
vraiment une perversion latence que ce
serait celle là où bat nancy pour la
jeux jeux d'été un défaut par exemple je
serai quoi la tempérance la tempérance
et étaient une injure
une copie dans un texte en avant par une
infirmité
j'ai failli y rester en chaise alors je
ne veux pas répondre eu un grave
accident là avec eux ce pca ainsi
morceaux sur la longueur et palois est à
man ça va ça fait bien terminer une
guerre au crime
c'était obligé d'être une guerre celle
des sacs parce qu'elle est là avec un
avis la cre était un dictateur même
canal un supplice
à celui de la question tu vois tu t'en
sors pas mal sauf oui
[Musique]
si tu étais un vis là à me dire oui oui
c'était le pire vis tu sais quoi la rue
lâche c'est les gens quand on l'attend
elle en fait le portrait chinois mardi
c'était une fleur la rigueur qui dès
l'annoncé et étaient en vie
ce serait là tu serais l'âge c'était une
guerre jusqu'à laquelle
oh mais la dernière parce qu'elle était
la plus terrible où alors
iran irak parce que c'était vraiment
terrible mais la dernière guerre a été
pas mal la dernière elle était pas mal
bien réussi c'était collaborateurs
suspects avait ne serait pas d'un cran
mais non mais c'est un jeu c'était un
grand collaborateur tu serais couilles
maurice sachs passé pas mal c'était un
supplice
oa supplice comment appelle-t-on ce
supplice où on écarte ça s'appelle de
laisser pas l'écarter parce que les
cartes et d'autres choses et gagner un
jour car l'écartèlement les cartels
système écartèlement peut-être aussi une
psychanalyse c'est une nation
les sites était un accident le pire des
choses c'est l'accident d'avion parce
que je prends sûrement l'avion et
comment ses traits à la base est très à
la mode en angleterre je trouve que
c'est meilleur
mais il faut pas prendre l'avion
si tu étais un insecte vit son casque à
c'était une infirmité ou une infirmité
aaron le théâtre c'était de ramasser ça
c'était une perversion toi c'était un
dictateur
toutefois si tu étais un poison c'est
bon signe a cité une guerre 3 cet été
une arme une arme alors c'était un
accident un accident pas d'avion parce
que je sais c'est pas
un ver qui casse parce que ça porte
bonheur et si tu étais une cicatrice
une stat et ce en un dialogue n'est pas
fermé
un supplice en dessous lice
la clinique zeljko le portrait chinois
si tu veux c'est définir la personnalité
de quelqu'un à travers des questions de
style
si tu étais une fleur par exemple lors
c'était une fleur tu serais quoi toi
comment leur tête une rose - comme ça
ouais tu vois c'est qu'on voit bien que
c'est un peu con ça alors nous personne
du bon alors nous ici on fait lentilles
portrait chinois avec ce qu'ils étaient
une injure
[ __ ] je gardais mon nom mais
maintenant ça va ils marchent bien en ce
moment c'est comme voir et ça va te
coller au cul s'il était un accident
je serai un accident de chasse
moi ça me fait ça me ferait bien marrer
mais j'aime bien quand ils se tirent un
peu entre eux se changer un peu michel
droit quoi ça fait un peu de répit aux
bestiaux tu connais la blague des de
deux chasseurs qui cassent la croûte ils
ont posé leurs fusils sur un arbre bien
des deux fusils qui glisse bien des deux
des chasseurs espèrent les deux
décharges de chevrotine en pleine gueule
et les biftecks h et puis son pote et se
retourne il volait bas il dit en fait
une tête il moi aussi j'ai eu peur il
était un collabo un collabo la balle je
vois en deuxième division face à laval
qui joue en deuxième division qu'il
était un bouton gros boutons un gros
bouton serait qu'il avait déjà un gros
point gros boutons ce sur la gueule de
mylène farmer
les fines ses cafés ses bobos les femmes
belges à l'heure elles s'endorment
toujours avec un doigt dans la
choupinette non parce qu'elles ont peur
que ces cicatrices
c'était un [ __ ] je vais tirer à 10 ans
des questions je vais essayer d'aider un
travesti logique je suis pas fait le
meilleur robert bardot qui me tente
est-ce que tu connais le portrait
chinois le portrait chinois
je te dis par exemple s'il était une
fleur quelles fleurs tu serais si la
marijuana c'est le piège
donc je vais pas répondre donc c'est
l'anti portrait chinois
j'y répondrai pas tu as répondu mon
peuple
si tu étais un défaut un défaut way a
redit son nom
[Applaudissements]
ah si c'est pas ça c'est comme un joker
tu peux le faire qu'une fois fin et ben
je vais l'employé qu'une fois malaga
s'est fait à la gtt une maladie une
maladie nerveuse tirons une maladie
nerveuse well as petites maladies
psychosomatiques qui donne des plaques
avant le rendez vous inscrits en titre
mais surtout le toit le mauvais la
mauvaise plaques
tu viens pour chercher du job d'un
rendez vous avec une fille mais moi je
me manifeste et tu sais pas comment me
soigner parce que c'est en toi la
solution
la maladie de timsit way intervenir veut
un insecte un insecte un mort pure en
petits morceaux et pas n'importe où le
morpion dans une petite forêt vierge
comme ça d'une femme du monde comme ça
je verrai tout le monde mais à toute la
journaliste notamment au coq je peux
changer de personnes comme ça un microbe
un microbe âgées pas dire le gonocoque
dira peut-être là tiens y'a un microbe
ce n'est pas son nom mais il se passe
par la salive et c'est la maladie de
l'amour tu sais que ça te donne un
nombre de globules blancs comme seul on
dit ah vous avez embrassé la pâle sida
non c'est la salive et lui rien n'est
plus comme ça elle a way sans toi c il y
en a qui logera
a aussi connu en mononucléose les
[ __ ] chercher sans n'ont pas d'accord
on est bien entouré
elle produit qui me la fiv s'il était un
dictateur avec mademoiselle je veux bien
un dictateur est peut-être rêvé d'être
andy d'annette tout le monde se lève
pour danette
[Applaudissements]
seul dictateur que tu supportes way gt1
vis à vis de plus
oui c'est trop faux pas je veux pas un
impôt un impôt sur les coûts [ __ ]
j'aurais de l'oseille on renfloue les
caisses de l'état tu me dois 300 bas
depuis le début et moi aussi je suis le
premier à payer 150 cet été un [ __ ] un
homme politique qui respecte pas le jeu
qui pense à lui
avant de penser à la nation ça c'est un
[ __ ] pas tous ses biens sa couette
talons mais t'as vu des fois je vends
l'autre des froids mais moins à temps il
ya quelqu'un là on m'a soufflé ça
m'arrive en général c'est tout seul chez
moi mais là et l'état on est aux folies
bergères je me sens un peu chez moi
ouais un bouton seul état sur le front à
qui il fait mal c'est un supplice un
supplice je peux pas répondre à
redescendre à dire elle pour deux coups
ok ok mais tu vois joker la chèvre
supplie de personnel en premier un
premier temps ma mère me le fais je
résiste pas
un poison un poison celui qu'a dans le
vert la halle autopsie on va te dire une
infirmité n'affirme le nez en trompette
et bah oui je me suis et attention c'est
un faux nez mois
oui je me suis fait refaire le même
geste était un assassin que tu serais
l'assassin eliot ness s'adresse à sa
[ __ ] mais t'as vu le nombre de mecs
ils bidonnent tendue cet épisode il fait
partie de la police ah ouais eliot ness
mais si tu étais un flic eliot ness vie
est-ce que tu connais le portrait
chinois de réputation par exemple je te
dise il était une fleur la quelle fleur
tu serais absolument à nous ici on fait
un truc un peu plus pervers sembl ait
maintenant at il tenu ses lentilles
portrait chinois s'ils étaient une
injure
vanessa paradis
ça va comme réponse c'était un accident
cardiaque
c'était un insecte moi qui adore les
baies de goji
[Musique]
ils montrent religieuse c'est un microbe
un microbe [ __ ] je tenais pas vraiment
et non des micros tu sais quel genre de
microbes
jean-louis un microbe ceux de jean louis
frot le fait a dit m
si tu étais un microbe unamid ouais
pourquoi parce que ça résiste bien
ouais ça dans l'est pendant les mauvais
moments ça se renseigne une harpie vingt
ans après ça recommence à faire chier
c'est le cas de le dire c'est pas mal à
toi si tu étais un dictateur répond pas
michel blanc dimanche
en deux mots
qu'est ce qu'un but dimanche un
dictateur mon père
le psychanalyste fait mal au coeur c'est
dur pour lui c'était une panne ou panne
bah voilà
[Applaudissements]
si tu étais une arme ah c'est sûr tu vas
répondre toi un couteau tu connection
les couteaux oui c'est ce que ça
signifie ah bon mon père me l'a dit une
fois mais je crois que ça mais oui
depuis que c'est un couteau pour un
psychanalyste
je sais pas pourquoi c'est quoi ouais
c'est un couteau non mais tu avais l'air
de savoir belge pas été dit que c'était
un une symbolique du sexe de l'homme
voilà tu y crois ça non elle croit pas
au sexe de l'homme à toi si tu étais un
chômeur moi je serai bien emmerdé avec
talent était chômeur quoi oui ça toucher
les assedic oui chômeurs
j'ai été malheureux ouais moi si tu peux
passer un message
oui non alors là ça fait ch et pas
combien de temps je sais de m'inscrire
en pologne parce qu'il m'a donné à moi
tu apprendras va évidemment et cette
gêne pas de prendre je sais pas de sens
bris pour faire 5 tenue de soirée et
après toucher les assedic pendant un an
non franchement c'est à dire ce qui me
gêne c'est de donner 60 % aux impôts sur
les 200 briques ensuite puis sur les 40
% qui restent de donner beaucoup pour
les assedic ensuite sur ce que me
reversent les assedic d'ordonner 60% aux
impôts
ouais ça ça me gêne beaucoup donc je
regrette pas non pas du tout mais quand
je donne 60 % impôts je ne pense pas je
ne demande pas qu'on me traite de cinq
jeux j'espère que quand je touche ce à
quoi j'ai droit
on peut me [ __ ] la paix par le traité
de [ __ ] d'accord ou alors sinon retour
compromettre à plein temps ça va tenir
si tu étais un professeur de danse de
danse c'est qu'il a fait aux yeux de
prof de piano lycée qui joue très bien
du piano
non j'ai un peu papa prof pas prêtes à
payer de concertiste ben euh enfin j'ai
failli j'ai pas été concertés quoi
c'était très dur oui moi pas j'ai failli
être gagnant de la république aussi
failli tout est vrai même ce que je fais
j'ai fais toi tu as failli faire du
trapèze c'est ça hein
et pourquoi tu dois te laisser tomber
non si je n'avais pas peur c'est plus
compliqué de faire ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui à bon ouais un jour sans la
moquette de coco c'est ce combat ne
tombe des cocos et je me suis il raflait
tout lasse enfants non mais je voulais
faire du trapèze et puis je me suis
présenté à l'école du cirque quand
j'avais 8 ans on m'a dit tu peux
attendre d'avoir dix ans alors entre les
deux j'étais impatient dû changer d'avis
tu veux un portrait chinois le portrait
chinois c'est quand on dit à quelqu'un
s'il était une fleur qu'elle flirte us
faire de toi c'est très con alors moi
j'étais préparé une petite interview
spéciale c'est l'anti portrait chinois
si c'était une injure l'open trop s'il
était un collabo le pen ouais
si c'était une maladie le pen l'a loupé
dit elle a lepénisé d'un accident enfin
je tire bois ouais si tu étais un
insecte je vais en mettre une
moustiques un sergent-chef région qui
transporte du mal à 10,1 pire que tout
va est une perversion ce serait quoi
comme vers version catholique
c'était une arme crayon était un bouton
de brian
c'était un supplice supplice de lire le
présent
ouais c'était un raciste toujours pareil
jean-marie rechange et 2 mais si tu
étais un immigré second fils soit sur
mon coin à la bouche
namibe affecte non vous pouvez venir
quand vous voulez parce que vous ne
bougez pas pendant le jingle j'étais en
train de regarder si c'est avec naomi il
faut le savoir quand elle rencontre un
homme pour la première fois il faut la
regarder dans les yeux sinon c'est même
pas la peine de la regarde assad mais
nous on se connaissait depuis longtemps
et j'ai regardé ses pieds mots qu'est ce
que vous pensez des caisses que
alors si vite guy lux vous connaissez le
portrait chinois
oui le portrait chinois c'est si tu
étais une fleur quelles fleurs serais-tu
bon l'an petit portrait chinois c'est
plus compliqué si vous étiez une injure
ce serait gros cons ah oui parce que
gros con c'est vraiment bien parce que
pour être un gros con il faut pas être
gros oui il suffit d'être con c'est vrai
ça al'avantage comme acheter belinda à
vous suivez là en tout à fait aulas l'a
commandé gros coup en anglais alors est
bon se poser la question précisément
mais on s'est dits textos petr cech
stopper sa chute c'est beau si vous
étiez une maladie la maladie de
parkinson
parce que ça me permettrait de continuer
à jouer des maracas le plus pour lui
dessiner pour le tout si vous étiez un
accident en art on parle d'accident
heureux un peintre dont le pinceau
dérape crée parfois une tâche magnifique
mais vous étiez une perversion je crois
que je suis une perversion une guerre un
coin un conflit nucléaire mondial ça
résoudrait pas mal de problèmes succès
sur le réchauffement de la terre ça
s'est réglé au moins si vous étiez un
avis le vis sans fin
c'est inventé par michel-ange une
trahison
vous savez je suis quelqu'un de fidèle
en amitié dans le travail et dans la vie
ce serait peut-être de vous révéler
des secrets touchant michel drucker à
michel drucker et son chien
oui parce que je les vois parfois dans
le bureau et je sais qu'il prend les
véritables décisions si vous étiez vous
étiez une arme un canon j'ai toujours
rêvé d'être un cas non valable en face
d'eux mais oui je sais il dit
[Applaudissements]
mareen kraeh en france quand une fille
est très jolie on dit c'est un canon un
canon belinda merci oui bien sûr tige
toujours là une cicatrice si vous étiez
une cicatrice le sourire
ouais une cicatrice qui ne se referment
jamais à la main tant il est vrai c'est
bon ça y est c'est bon allez il est trop
fort si vous étiez un [ __ ] vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est rare que je ne trouve pas un si
vous y était un dictateur
on peut pas dire vous l'aviez d'une fois
le maître du monde
ouais oui parce que je fais pas les
choses à moitié
oui donc maîtres du monde ou rien maître
du monde aurélien si vous étiez une
infirmité la calvitie
oui parce que c'est celle infirmité qui
a des avantages de même c'est pas
douloureux oui ça fait gagner du temps
le matin pour se coiffer et puis ça rend
tellement séduisant et c'est vrai bah
vous en tous les cas c'est aux a
vachement gaffe ça m'a pas permis à
l'homme chauve ça vous ça vous fait fuir
non ça me fait rire faire est
complètement show bien et ben voila je
fais pas ça sur mon coeur me campbell
[Applaudissements]
histoire est réglé mon père et je vais
donc ne va pas dompter a glissé ce qu'il
veut pas enlever les eaux et son chapeau
et quand j'avais 4 ans et report il a je
lui enlever son chapeau il était chez
lui après noir si vous étiez un microbe
la grippe vous vous tombez vous êtes
microbes et vous allez vous avez la
possibilité de donner la grippe
je sais pas au chanteur carlos ou à
naomi campbell
vous hésitez pas à huy bancaire vous
choisissez carlos
bien sûr si vous étiez nasa regard si
vous étiez un terroriste carlos
nous étions une torture une torture oui
tortues ninja oui dit comme règle d'or
valait il est con il est con il sait
bien que j'allais dire zoé la torture
rapide si vous étiez une humiliation
élimination en revanche pas déjà fait
pareil c'est comme un conte a pas
arriver à 100 at il risqué humiliation à
une bonne réponse en même temps et si
vous étiez une mort
la petite mort bonne réponse ici on ne
bouge pas
moi
c'est une rupture a pas de livre isme
rupture d'anévrisme voit pas vrai c'est
rapide une injure va [ __ ] le comté
mort qui tâche il a souvent pris au mot
dite des 'quatre c'est repos 10 me et
une maladie incurable de toute façon
vrai dans la griffe parce que ça met les
gens à plat un accident travail bien sûr
c'est donc une perversion par se parler
de soi même à la troisième personne a
oui comme alain delon de l'aunis mme
delaunay mariage de la pop lui il ya des
plombiers aussi monsieur bah oui ils
disent comme ça comment il va et j'adore
un vice par l'alcool les femmes
enfin ça va ensemble non une arme un
pistolet ou un supplice je ne ferai pas
aux chinois mais le monopoly ve
[Rires]
moi j'aurais répondu la sono dix mois
mais ça je suis dit ça tous les jours
maintenant c'est ça devient lourd c'est
une routine si vous étiez un dictateur
je serai metteur en scène si vous étiez
une torture à la torture jean pierre
foucault
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc vous connaissez le portrait chinois
si j'étais une fleur je serai un mieux
au titre ça c'est l'anti portrait
chinois par exemple si vous étiez une
injure
il a une très belle dans fool for love
sam shepard cber moi pas de ta mère de
décor si vous étiez une maladie la
syphilis
si vous étiez un accident une rupture
d'anévrisme
parce que ça arrive brutalement comme ça
c'est un accident mais interne une
perversion
se ronger les ongles cgt ni guerre une
guerre civile une révolution vous étiez
avis le voyeurisme justice est une
trahison
l'adultère une arme une arme blanche
un supplice le supplice de fins morceaux
c'est quoi c'est qu'il ya une photo dont
les larmes d'eros de bataille avec un
chinois qui sera découpé en morceaux et
on va son regard ecstasy si vous êtes
découvert bataille l'âge de 15 ans vrai
aidé en viande c'est dans dix ans nous
il ya pierre angélique est dédié à
pierre angélique c'est ça si vous étiez
une cicatrice si vous étiez un poison la
digitaline parce que guy barça suisse
était avec la digitaline il en faut 60
gouttes pour mourir donc au moins je
connais les doutes si vous étiez une
[ __ ]
voilà non j'hésite entre
les du macbeth monica levinsky les deux
[Rires]
oui tu te fais du mal pour rien si vous
êtes j'avais un pot le droit de
succession si vous étiez une table ne
pas savoir répondre à une de vos
questions
un dictateur dieu une infirmité
l'incontinence nasa
sid ahmed runs alain j'ai écrit une
pièce sur lui avant si vous étiez un
microbe un colibacille si vous étiez un
terroriste je sais pas encore ce qu'on
en avait quelques-uns à toutes les
semaines ça n'existe pas encore j'étais
en vacances le mois dernier ouais j'en
ai pas vus zéro puisque h c'est normal
c'est le papa qui vante le châtel
record si vous étiez une torture l'heure
les chatouille
ah bon si vous étiez mort un crime
passionnel
[Musique]
ancien l'auteur si vous étiez un défaut
vous sur lesquels des faux jeu je suis
myope
ouais c'est formidable quand on est bien
vous êtes dans la même pièce que didier
schuller et vous le voyez pas ouais ça
peut aider
si vous étiez un accident dégueulasse
j'ai fait un accident naturel peut-être
j'ai rêvé d'être un raz-de-marée parce
que la mer ont dû fait seul avaler
tellement de choses qu'un quelques axes
revanche si vous étiez une perversion de
voyeur le voyeurisme gérer j'aimerais
bien rentrer voir les gens comme ça
qu'on met dans la tête
wei dans leur tête mais aussi de chez
eux ça j'adore rsa une mouche si vous
étiez une guerre la norme aurait
débarquement en normandie
ça c'était il y avait des français qui
ont débarqué le moulin des fusilliers
marins qui ont débarqué en normandie
les premiers les premiers sur la plage
de riva-bella et beaucoup sont bons
c'est vrai que c'était très beau si vous
étiez une arme un opinel ou un truc
comme ça pour le figa tel écoute aux
portes alors un supplice il ya un très
beau supplice
que j'ai en tête qui est celui de
tantale mais il est dans l'eau et puis
l'eau arrive jusque là il a soif je
propose qu'on replace le par dudu
vendront d'année ou par un petrus un
très bon bordeaux
c'est une cicatrice je vais pas vous la
montrer mais je suis ouvert de la jusque
là oui c'est la mer et j'aime bien je la
touche ah oui attouchements si vous
étiez une [ __ ]
vous seriez qui moi j'aime pas le mot
parce que j'ai jamais dit ça une femme
mais bien dommage en soit chacun son
truc mais j'ai jamais dit ça il fane
jamais c'est à chacun son truc c'est on
est tous comme ça normal
voilà je pensais je pensais à simone
signoret dans les diaboliques n'en est
pas là pas la personne personnages ou
madame de merteuil non dangereux
devenait une femme qui fait des trucs
extraordinaires amants diaboliques
mais qui arrive à faire affaire tué son
amant par la maîtresse de cette annonce
est si vous étiez un dictateur quel
dictateur seriez-vous j'aime pas ça je
pense aller charlie chaplin quand il
joue avec audel il s'appelle la
dictature et oui avec un ballon que le
monde c'est pas drôle si vous n'êtes
jamais voulu qu'on pose ces questions là
mais on peut déposer son matelas posés à
toi la prochaine si vous étiez une
torture 18 tête à tête avec la reine
d'angleterre
ah oui on s'est fait
c'est les oreilles si vous étiez une
torture moi je m'appellerai sodomites ou
alors si j'étais une torture je
m'appellerai cocaïne par exemple voilà
ça c'est une vraie réponse et c'est pour
ça qu'il ya des questions au bois de
tout à l'heure la mâche à la panique
voilà un dictateur ou autre mais un mec
qui roule en ferrari
il a envie de jouer là si vous étiez un
terroriste ou seriez qui comme
terroriste un mec qui roule en ferrari
et il s'arrête pas au cas où si vous
étiez une injure vous seriez quelle
injure on va manger la culotte à ta
vieille si vous êtes une conversion
jeune star je vais star en forme et vous
êtes en forme là si vous étiez à vis à
vis à vis je dirais comme ils
s'appellent l'autre était michael youn
ouais parce que quelque part ça va vite
c'est le morning live sur m6 tous les
matins là mais c'est même pas pour lui
faire quoi que ce soit si je suis pas
démago moi c'est vraiment parce que je
le crois il a mal quelque part si vous
étiez une arme
si j'étais une arme
ni ta mère mais avec pas chez sony et si
vous étiez mort
enfin un truc bien horrible la tête dans
une baignoire
parce que veut on veut que je dise où je
vais mon magot ouais d'accord un truc
ridicule pour être je m'attends mourir
pour savoir d'accord ouais nord qui sert
à la tête
blablabla et oncle armait dessous ça
franchement ça c'est pire que de te
brûler les pieds ou parce que le gaz ou
des choses comme ça on accorde un moment
d'inconscience 6,8 coin là c'est
vraiment c c on peut te l'a serrée et le
corps humain trop bien fait ça doit
faire un moment donné tu perd conscience
ouais mais quand on te noies c'est
claustrophobie ces mêmes ceux qui savent
pas ce que c'est après las moment des
maquettes
france soir vous étiez de mort d'un mois
dans mon livre je sais qu'il marque est
très belle à un moment il raconte la
mort de kafka qu'elle est très belle
parce qu'ils demandent de la morphine il
et il est en train de mourir silence et
d'amour luxueuse en attend ils demandent
de la morphine l'équipe en a pas ou lits
dont il y en a pas il dit cette phrase
extraordinaire dit tuez moi sinon vous
êtes un assassin
voilà ça sera le dernier mot de cette
interview françois léotard la couleur d
am c'est chez grasset
ce n est pas son premier livre messieurs
on n'échange pas pendant l'été galles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien si vous étiez un défaut si c'est un
défaut je serai ce sera dans ce jour une
injure pas ce soir chéri j'ai la
migraine influent une maladie j'aurai la
bougeotte une perversion ce serait de me
le marquer avec une poupée gonflable un
vis vis
j'ai pas se serait appelée ta femme par
exemple une trahison décès en silicone
ouais bien une arme une arme des talons
aiguilles
1 une cicatrice une une marque de rouge
à lèvres sur le bout de ma de ma cravate
un poison
ce sera une une compilation de julio
iglesias a volé femme un [ __ ] un
[ __ ] un [ __ ] ce serait un alcoolique
au volant oui parce que ce que ce que ce
que vous dites en fait c'est que vous en
voulez pas au monde entier en 1971 tous
à supporter tout ça est ce que tes rides
c'est les gens qui se font plus rire
c'est terrible mais qui passent dans la
rue la fille qui ce fait est un type qui
sait me dont il peut carrément
identifier celui qui a fêté sa vie en
l'air si vous étiez un dictateur ce
serait se serait lolita 1 italie tu as
tout manon si vous étiez une torture ce
serait je sais pas moi qui ont dégonflé
pneus ouais une humiliation
l'élimination complique mon fauteuil
roulant ce serait bien dans la merde
un accident au ce serait tomber amoureux
[Applaudissements]
voilà jean marie bigard et bouger ouais
si vous étiez un défaut la gentillesse
ouais mais c'est un super défaut ça on
n'est pas à l'abri d'ailleurs de la
gentillesse des autres si vous étiez une
injure allez tous vous faire [ __ ]
sale mérite d'être clair mais si vous
étiez une maladie une maladie
je serai peut-être la maladie a oui je
serai la maladie de gilles de la
tourette tu connais ce mardi j'ai vu ça
l'autre jour c'est extraordinaire si un
mec qui parle normalement c'est comme un
tick tock je suis con ça paie et tout
d'un coup le mec sort une insanité quoi
ouais c'est charles avec lui tu dis bien
thierry j'aime bien ton émission va te
faire [ __ ] connard
mais il ya on voit pas assez souvent
laurent baffie toi il veut continuer à
parler normalement vous aussi alzheimer
c'est pas mal ouais
d'ailleurs tu sais que robinson crusoé
sur la fin de sa vie il avait la maladie
d'alzheimer amant qui sait comment ils
appelaient vendredi
non l'autre jour
jean marie bigard si vous étiez un
accident je suis un accident mais oui si
vous étiez une perversion je suis une
perversion vous mais qui savent asie en
chaîne si vous étiez une guerre je serai
la guerre des boutons ce que la guerre
maintenant c'est avec des boutons mari
et puis elle se fait économiquement il
des boutons tu vois bien chirurgicale et
propre sur dix ans cette rencontre quand
un mec sur un bouton à bon père de
famille il dit bon le l'embargo au
godinand l'embargo volet il appuie sur
un bouton y tue à coups sur 3500
personnes par jour par exemple l'embargo
sur l'irak a tué un million et demi de
personnes dont cinq cent mille enfants
de moins de cinq ans simplement toi ici
et bien aligné toi ça cent mille enfants
toi là j'ai pas vu beaucoup de minutes
de silence pour ça non mais un embargo
ça tue à coups sûrs et et puis bon bah
voilà donc c'est là que ça serait
vraiment la guerre des boutons si vous
étiez une arme je serai excalibur si
j'étais une arme déjà parce qu'elle sait
pas tirer pas tout le monde a pu le
remarquer et si tu sais bientôt servir
tu peux pourfendre certain nombre de
gros cons avec excalibur chan excalibur
bien sûr
si vous étiez une cicatrice cicatrices
chez la cicatrice de de l'appendicite
parce que c'est pas loin de la salle des
fêtes
si vous étiez un poison
je serai une femme ouais
[Applaudissements]
audio
tj 12 dans sa main à temps quand on en
bouffe avec des amis je me tourner vers
ma femme et j'ai dit tais toi toi mal
baisées et grâce à qui veut dire à toi
chez rue balore qui ce qui commande
[Musique]
ah justement si vous étiez une [ __ ]
ce sera une chaîne genre béatrice dalle
toi ouais parce que j'adore béatrice 1
c'est pas ça la question contraire même
s'il adore super mais maintenant en plus
internet comme cela parce que c'est non
je dis j'ai dit béatrice dalle parce que
c'est le type de fille qui est
d'ailleurs de cordialement détesté par
les autres femmes a certainement parce
que c'est vrai que tu as envie de
grimper dessus et tu sais que tu vas
jamais y arriver quoi et donc c'est très
fantasmé league
si vous étiez un dictateur
charlie chaplin city and assassins rocco
siffredi je serai c'est une idée de film
et j'espère c'est que je te dis ça sera
un serial buteur mais qui tuerait des
blondes à coups de beats on
rechercherait dans toute la france
là bas ça si vous étiez une torture
une torture un truc pire que jean pierre
foucault un jeu c'est pas le jeu serait
un vélo un vélo c'est une torture la
preuve les ils sont obligés de prendre
de la drogue pour monter dessus et c'est
pour te dire que c'est dur c'est quand à
vélo là sur deux connaît le truc r oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est le vélo que michel drucker a
mis en vente pour michaël blanc
oui
c'est génial ça c'est pour le blanc
michel drucker mais tu vois rien demandé
à moi bah tu peux donner ce que tu veux
un dunk claudia n'ont peut-être pas mais
non mais qu'est ce que je vais te donner
a fléchi et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nos jours en jours
je l'aide donnée tracy la table
construit des caméras cache-toi des
caméras et de le saison mickaël alors
pour le micro je fais comment battu non
mais le slip sais pas c'est pas
suffisant tiens tu sais tu sais tu sais
que depuis bercy
je ne quitte pas si chaussures oui parce
que c'est elle qui sont entrés devant
les 13000 personnes
eh ben je donne les chaussures et le
sait le liban
il s'est invité blanc
il a ajouté l'hôpital
cauchon
conditions
[Applaudissements]
à
merci pour lui
michael situe son pote cabane avec 5
voilà je l'aï bien
je trouve ça vachement bien que gasquet
a d'abord réussi le sortir de là parce
que mais qui lie à perpète
c'est un patrice alègre il a pris 22 ans
avoir tué six gonzesses et lui pour un
peu de shit il est à perpète donc c'est
si on arrive à faire bouger ça et si tu
y arrives et ben ça sera vachement bien
parce que ça va faire école bah ouais il
faudrait que chirac concède un peu aussi
un waza et vas-y jacques herlin jacques
un souffle et une mort je serai une
petite mort c'est la petite mort
ouais la petite bord que tu as vu dans
les yeux de ta femme que tu l'as fait
jouir à coup en 69 n a pas que ça on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
pour nous
si vous étiez un défaut un défaut
d'attention se rentrer sur scène la
braguette ouverte par exemple par
exemple si vous étiez une injure un fast
food en bord de mer une maladie la
sinusite une partie de mes cachets je
les donne pour la recherche pour la
ceniza ouais mais parce que toutes les
maladies importantes été prises comme le
sida ou moi j'essayais de trouver une
maladie en proportion que ma notoriété
si vous étiez une guerre une guerre la
guerre de troie
pourquoi que voilà ce que la guerre de
troie n'aura pas lieu hamilton
si vous étiez un avis le nooyi sme le
nooyi sme c'est parce que c'est celle
arnouil non le vous avez mélangisme vous
connaissez ouais bien sûr un fétichisme
le voile rigide parce que tout ça est le
nou isme c'est une partouze où les gens
viennent déguisés en nouilles
ah oui non ça vient des états unis c'est
très sain moi j'en ai fait une tribune
coquillettes et franchement je ne veux
pas je me suis éclaté c'est arrivé en
france en janvier 2002 falloir un petit
peu patienter mais il ya un truc qui va
arriver aussi en france à ce prix de
l'acier le ciment le zyban arrêter de
fumer
génial il paraît que c'est radical reste
moi je cherche le moyen magique pour
arrêter de fumer parce que j'ai aucune
volonté
il paraît qu'il faut un petit peu de
volonté et ça agit directement sur les
cellules qui sont dépendantes du thème
du tabac pas de goudron dedans ni de
nicotine il ya le nazisme qui va arriver
en france il ya aussi bas après chacun
voit midi à sa lepi le terrorisme aussi
préparez vous bien si vous étiez une
arme tarte à la crème
un supplice chef opérateur sur un film
porno c'est un a fait 120 à les oublier
c'est vrai que j'ai dit billon oui si
vous étiez une cicatrice new york jean
ba je vous dis à chaud embêté parce
qu'il a été très brillant et moi j'ai
été très nul je vous dise pourquoi c'est
parce que je m'étais préparé sur des
trucs comme des préservatifs
m
dépenser peu sucer ses baisers j'avais
jamais assez aux gens normaux à ce que
vous pensez de sucer c'est tromper
moi je suis pas premier ministre et
parer à tout ça et là tu sur quoi vous
m'interrogez sur l'académie je suis
imprévisible gens normaux gens que lui
et vous avez été très bien puis djamel
vous a aidé et je le sens je ne sais pas
et c'est pas vrai on fera avec plaisir
si vous étiez un dictateur un dictateur
l'audimat
ouais bonne réponse non
[Applaudissements]
tu étais dictateur démissionner si vous
êtes une infirmité quelqu'un qui
mémorise par les prénoms
ouais mon père et il me donne les deux
noms de mes frères et le mien s'appelle
david bernard stéphane et encore ça
s'est amélioré parce qu'avant on avait
un chien qui s'appelait pépettes savez
quoi je vous signale que ça s'acquiert
ça ce don là s'acquiert exactement
connaissait les prénoms avant et puis
tout à coup ils m'échappe mais le vôtre
vous voulez le mia ça va encore mais
parce qu'il faut dire qu'il est facile
facile si vous étiez en assassin à
l'assassin landre est ce que vous savez
que quand landre a été condamné à mort a
tout à voir la dernière minute il ya un
prêtre que le voir et qui lui a dit mon
enfant pourra vous apporter les secours
la religion est ce que vous croyez à
dieu ce que vous croyez à notre vie et
l'envoi a répondu oh mon père est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est le moment de
plaisantes
si vous étiez un microbe un microbe par
le microbe c'est difficile parce que par
exemple claudia schiffer grippe et je
n'embrasse way michèle alliot marie en
pleine santé je l'appelais si vous étiez
une torture une torture passé une nuit
en copain avec une fille sublime ça vous
est déjà arrivé à tout le monde
1 je te promets je ne touche pas ouais
c'était une vraie métallique qui me
touchait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien lu si vous étiez une humiliation
une humiliation à une fois j'étais
c'était dans un dîner j'étais très jeune
à dîner chez un copain et j'étais
tellement gêné d'être à table avec les
parents de mon copain que je me suis mis
à caresser le chien sous la table et un
moment donné je me suis aperçu que
c'était la jambe de la mère de mon
copain c'était dans les années 80 il va
des jupes avec des deux les morceaux de
laine comme ça et vous voyez comme on
vient quand vous vieillissez vous croyez
vous caresser la jambe
dernière question stéphane c'est bien
stéphane suis pas faire comme votre père
vous n'êtes pas d'avis si vous étiez
mort la mort de james dean à l'âge de
jeanne calment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup de portrait chinois ça veut
dire il ya le portrait chinois si vous
étiez une fleur je serai à myosotis et
l'anti portrait chinois par exemple
c'est si vous étiez un défaut si j'étais
un défaut ouais si j'annonce si j'étais
un défaut mais quel défaut vous seriez
l'esprit de sérieux je crois je crains
que je crains c'est bien si vous étiez
d'injures le silence si vous étiez une
maladie la lucidité un accident la
chance une perversion le goût du secret
si vous étiez un vice si j'étais un vis
à la si belle fera le si beau titre de
larbaud ce vice impuni la lecture si
j'étais invite je serai la lecture une
trahison
je serai comme ces gens qui militent ou
qui se bat contre leur tribu contre leur
camp par exemple je ne sais pas les
aristocrates ou les prêtres français en
89 qui rejoignent le tiers état c'est
une des plus belles attitudes me
semble-t-il ceux qui choisissent de
penser contre eux mêmes ou contrôler
leur penser contre soi même penser
contre m oui ou contre les siens les
pieds noirs qui devenait porto qui
prenait le parti du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie
ça ça me semble une attitude très noble
city est une arme
si j'étais une arme un stylo c'est le
seul dont je suis capable de me servir
c'est la différence entre vous et nabab
lui a répondu un cutter la semaine
dernière moi ce sera sûrement d'autres
et différence dans cette interview que
ça permet de si vous étiez un supplice
la volupté une cicatrice le souvenir
notamment des volutes et si vous étiez
un poison la vérité dont ce génie s'il
disait qu'elle était le poison des
dictatures que lesdits nature se
corroder par le travail de la vérité se
situe une panne je crois que j'essaierai
de dérégler d'envoyer un virus dans les
derniers ordinateurs de ben laden ceux
avec lesquels il est sans doute en train
de préparer ses prochains attentats ray
un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur j'oblige ray et
thierry ardisson a diffusé chaque samedi
10 minutes en boucle l'image de l'angola
et du burundi que blatter si vous êtes
une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité la surdité plus
il était une infirmité
je remplace date et non la patience 1
l'impatience moi c'est probablement mon
pire défaut enfin voilà la patience ça
ça si j'étais un assassin jeu
j'essaierai d'assassiner pam avoisinera
surgit la mauvaise part de moi-même que
je connais bien et ça en général c'est
un crime parfait mais celui là si vous
étiez à microbes
j'essaierai d'être d'être un microbe
sympathique des train d'être un microbe
de gauche qui irait chercher de
préférence les [ __ ] mais parfois les
cons mais surtout des salles aux
microbes sélectif une torture je ne sais
pas si je voulais torturer quelqu'un je
crois que ce serait la différence
voilà une humiliation je me suiciderai
parce que je si j'étais une imitation
jeu mais je crois que je ne supporte ni
d'être humilié ni encore moins de
supporter l'humiliation des autres donc
je disparaîtrai dans votre nuage de
fumée jugement dernier serge lama
j'accompagnerai savamment obligatoires
c'est un opéra ni si vous étiez un
terroriste je serai le colonel fabien
c'est à dire je serai un bon terrorisme
la définition d'un bon terroristes c'est
quelqu'un qui défend une juste cause et
qui n'a pas d'autre moyen que la
violence de la défendre donc posé des
bombes dans paris en 42 ce colonel
fabien
ça je crois que c'est du bon terrorisme
et ça n'a évidemment rien à voir avec
cette caricature que sont les
terroristes d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer quoi
c'est comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer
qui était un mot de malraux et qui est
elle a deux filles
la devise du commandant massoud ray et
si vous étiez une bourre moi je serais
lui je serais la petite mort en avant
[Applaudissements]
andré glucksmann si vous étiez un défaut
vous seriez quoi moi empire une injure
c'est c'est celui qui dit qui l'est
c'est une maladie se croire bon se
croire un très bon qui veut faire l'ange
fait la bête un accident le genre humain
une perversion un sandwich saucisse
nutella ou bien une glace vanille
camembert c est y ait une guerre
la prochaine ou bien la guerre de
tchétchénie qui dure depuis 300 ans
mais plutôt du côté de tchétchènes
soutien vis un mont blanc mais pas le
papa pas la montagne une meringue avec
crème de marron une crème chantilly
c'était en fait c'est la véritable
madeleine de proust et ça se vendait
chez rebelles meyer et le magasin a été
débaptisée par les nazis parce que ça ce
n'est pas vraiment tout à fait français
si vous étiez une trahison l'oubli une
arme les couverts en matière plastique
du vol mais qu'on a dit si tu y es un
supplice le match télévision et je sais
qu'un chien qu une cicatrice celles qui
ne se referme pas
ground zero si j'étais un dictateur vous
soyez qui eût pu c'est une invention
d'un lycéen 1,88 à 15 ans en 1888 en
1888 qui anticipent eux et ben laden et
polpot un staline et hitler et qui en
plus est drôle si vous étiez une
infirmité les pieds dans le plat en
assassin raskolnikov mohammed atta rien
de ce qui est inhumain ne nous est
étranger si vous étiez un terroriste à
un terroriste qui réussit qui fait
beaucoup de morts qui est félicité par
tout le monde qui va boire le thé avec
la reine d'angleterre je serais vous l'a
dit mme irles a dit mir rawicz poutine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
8 bouger gabriel baisse 9 si vous étiez
un défaut la conscience défauts mineurs
c'est pas mal et conforme si vous étiez
une injure à une agir alors je parlerai
italien parce que l'italien la langue de
l'amour mais aussi la langue des
insultes je dirais farah bhoutan ouhlala
bon de personnes c'est une entrée la
skunk anansie ya c'est beau ça sonne le
réveil si vous étiez une perversion
j'ai pas dire on en ces temps de carême
je dirais une messe noire
je vous étiez une guerre à le siège de
la rochelle à cause des trois
mousquetaires de d'artagnan leur plein
si vous étiez un vice la gourmandise une
trahison
est-ce que je peux rester avec alexandre
dumas je dirais le le crucifix d'aramis
quant à caen à d'artagnan dit traître tu
nous as fait jurer sur le crucifix d'une
frondeuse c'est le pacifique lui a
offert à ramiste la duchesse de
longueville et je copie si vous étiez
une arme à la meilleure enchère la seule
la vraie le style de la seule qui fasse
peur le fil au pays de galles et sortir
sa [ __ ] des noms
[Rires]
si vous étiez une cicatrice un chagrin
d'amour
un poison la ciguë un récent littéraire
ou le jura oui c'est pas mal aussi
si vous étiez un dictateur et depuis que
beigbeder fait la campagne de lui je
dirais staline ce grand calomnier car je
pense que sa ligne gagne est comme si
vous étiez à gaza lacenaire ouais c'est
une torture à dents vous savez dans
françois 1er fernandel il ya la chèvre
num et du sel oui alors ça ça doit être
terrible
si vous étiez une mort j'ai écrit un
poème sur la mort plus tard beaucoup
plus tard la radio les journaux tu
apprends donc je suis mort à cette
nouvelle le visage oublié de ton amant
flottera un certain devant tes yeux ton
corps se souviendra de notre
incomparable patients pointé 15 ans
seront rendus ta bouche sera ivre du vin
perdu et ton coeur se serrera
fugitivement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi
ou qui j'espère que je ne serai pas
l'envi mais peut-être l'envi si vous
étiez une injure tabernacle
c'est une injure que j'ai entendu au
québec et maintenant comme on dit ça
fait chier partout et même à la
télévision j'ai décidé de dire taberna
c'est dur les chanteurs québécois murat
peux vous en parler
s'ils tiennent accident la chute à vélo
j'aime bien faire du vélo mais peut-être
que je n'ai pas une forme olympique et
j'aime bien les descentes car je fais du
vélo c'est comme le vélo michel drucker
ici voilà il ya plus de celle ci vous
étiez une perversion l'amour conjugal
une guerre la guerre des nerfs
un vice la lecture quotidienne de
l'équipe service vis oui je vis c'est
bon les intellos souvent si ça a un nom
mais mois de ça et c'est cet ancien mais
voilà même les sionistes les jours ouais
s'il était une trahison à bas ce serait
la trahison des idéaux de ma jeunesse
généreuse grégaire et un peu débile way
fait qu'aujourd'hui vous je pars
remettre de l'huile sur le feu mais vous
pensez que c'est dépassé ça non je pense
qu'il faut essayer de réfléchir
autrement je parlais tout à l'heure d'un
coeur intelligent c'est une expression
je n'ai pas inventé paraît-il c'est
l'expression du roi salomon et 1 à
rennes que reprend à son compte
donc il s'agit pas d'opposer l'émotion à
la raison mais il s'agit d'être dans
l'émotion à la hauteur de la singularité
des événements si vous étiez une arme
le pistolet à eau vous étiez un supplice
l'écriture une cicatrice assez dur je ne
sais pas peut-être une très longue ligne
de la main oui ça peut toujours servir
vous étiez un poison l'insomnie un impôt
assis j'étais un impôt jeu taxerait le
bruit à mort du portable
le bruit de vos épaules vous étiez une
panne une panne d'inspiration un
dictateur alors si j'étais un dictateur
je d un vent très les portables et
j'interdirais la musique d'ambiance
ah bon ah oui la musique d'ambiance dans
les restaurants dans les cafés les
agresseurs dans la nièvre est dans l'est
dans les magasins terre la musique
contre la musique d'ambiance c'est une
infirmité peut-être justement une
certaine surdité à la musique
je ne suis pas été éduqué dans la
musique donc je suis un peu sourd et je
le regrette beaucoup
j'ai un microbe staphylocoque doré ah
oui c'est chioui souhaitiez une plaie
wayne aurait toujours une torture
[Musique]
la page blanche une humiliation eux
j'essaierai de pas trop la ramener si
vous étiez un terroriste je change de
métier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous me décevez mais c'est vraiment mais
ils ont répété non c'est un vrai public
de télévision regardez ils ont répété la
plomberie cas aujourd'hui attention la
blu drucker
[Musique]
par exemple
c'est aussi là
c'est un vrai public de télévision et
retraite si vous étiez un défaut la
naïveté
si vous étiez un accident un accident
médiatique une perversion la fouace
innocence une guerre le procès de jeanne
d'arc à mener contre saison que lui
dis-je un vice à la vertu
une trahison c'est mentir à soi-même une
arme l'amour un supplice le vide une
cicatrice le z de zorro qui fait sur le
ventre des méchants un poison
si vous étiez un assassin et ben c'était
pas bien de le dire mais moi je suis
tout à fait sérieusement pour
l'euthanasie donc je serais pour aller
tuer des gens qui ont envie de crever et
je le ferai
c'est une torture prix d'ami si vous
étiez une injure je twitte à merde
non
si vous étiez une injure grospatapouf
way groupe à davos que je milite pour le
retour des des insultes
inoffensif facile simple oui voilà c'est
sa période si vous voulez y est mathew
tait si vous me dites je ne supporte pas
grospatapouf y aller avec toute la haine
que vous pouvez essayer pour voir
grospatapouf voilà vous n'êtes pas
crédible j'ai pas envie de vous taper
c'est le retour à la paix si vous étiez
une maladie une maladie l'acné l'acné
parce que ça n'aviez beaucoup quand vous
étiez petit énormément
disons qu'à une époque si on regardait
bien entre mes boutons on peut voir mes
yeux a donc constitué un petit peu le
niveau
si vous étiez un accident un accident je
serai le début d'une liaison ce que je
suis un très très mauvais dragueur donc
à chaque fois le début c'est un accident
c'est une perversion enregistrer les
chiffres et des lettres et faire des
compiles
[Rires]
c'est une guerre la vie de couple
évidemment là et dire que tout le monde
peut vivre un vis à vis le bon mot parce
que comme beaucoup d'humoristes ça
m'arrive de dire le contraire de ce que
je pense pour faire un bon beau ouais
donc c'est une vraie vie ce une trahison
ne plus être supporters du paris
saint-germain jusque quand les
supporters ces avis et en ce moment on
va voir du mérite pour supporter du
paris saint germain
donc j'ai numérique
[Musique]
si vous étiez une arme le cynisme
cynisme parce que c'est un état d'esprit
qui permet de relativiser beaucoup de
choses ouais un supplice une soirée
diapos famille sans hésiter une
cicatrice à bas quelque chose dont je me
suis parmi ces à la fin des forbans sas
est resté ouvert et j'ai du mal à
deviner franchement le départ de bébert
ouais si vous étiez un poison la
kryptonite la kryptonite ces poisons
enfin c'est la pierre qui fait du mal à
superman parce que quand j'étais petit
je voulais être super héros d'ailleurs
je vous soutiens impôts l'autographe ce
que je trouve que c'est l'impôt le plus
sympathique que j'ai payé depuis que je
passe à la télévision et j'ai beaucoup
de mal à gérer ça parce que j'ai
toujours pression qu'on se fout de ma
gueule
je me demande pourquoi les gens vont me
demander un autographe en général il ya
deux attitudes d'ailleurs je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais il ya des gens
qui ne demandent un autographe gym et
c'est pour qui pour marquer de choses
fait passer pour moi
où il ya celui qui assume pas qui dit
ouais non tu peux me donner un
autographe
c'est pas pour moi c'est pour ma petite
soeur ah ouais c'est bien comment ta
petite soeur christophe
douzy team panne à la page blanche ouais
celle qui me fait le plus peur un
dictateur le pèse personne une infirmité
la renault kangoo
[Rires]
ça andré rieu c'est très bon un microbe
gérard miller s'est dit mme vergnon la
créa des écrivains des intellos qui nous
font des réponses
si vous étiez une plaie une plaie la
playstation ça c'est mon côté je ne
nourris donc y aller tranquille pour
l'émission une humiliation faire la
vaisselle
un terroriste un publicitaire si j'étais
mort
une pendaison avec un grille pain parce
que si vous calculez bien votre coup
quand les gens vous découvre il ya des
taux ce qui leur saute à la gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi il a bougé ou pas bien alors
lentilles pas vous connaissez le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois ces
sites étaient une fleur je serai un news
autisme et en allant du portrait chinois
c'est juste la mer c'est si vous étiez
une rupture par exemple une rupture de
rythme dans le tour de rythme une injure
or la vache à huy c5 non mais tu
m'énerves si ces cantons une incursion
relance à quelqu'un ou ses champs
qu'elle appuiera jure pourrait dire à
quelques violents nadine de rothschild
non j'aime pas ça les a vus tu m'énerves
sa cuisse du tout mais tu es fou la
violence des prolétaires oui mais bon
mais je peux pas on va se faire censurer
tu es malade rome et à gueule euh pardon
j'étais malade et les jantes et vitrail
de grottes merde veut dire [ __ ] voir
annoncer des pouvoirs mais je peux
prétendre non non il réside
il ya des choses que je peux dire on
t'envoie dans le métier 1
si vous étiez une maladie alors une
maladie qui serait pas grave mais qui
pourrait par exemple donner de la fièvre
parce que je sais pas moi j'ai des
souvenirs d'enfant donc jamais j'avais
de la fièvre
j'étais dans mon lit puis je sais pas
c'était un état que qui était assez
agréable jambon coquillonne
comportements d'espèces non mais ça non
mais juste que ça je tournais un peu
j'avais comme un comme inverti ça
donnait comme un vertige comme un truc
un peu connue là et c'était pas
désagréable vanille qui donne de la
filiale ce n'était pas grave
ouais si vous étiez une guerre aubin une
guerre de mots alors passez moi j'aimais
bien ça alors une légale que faut le
garder dans ouais mais enfin quand on
imite les bruits tous âges avaient bien
fait rue voilà tout ça quand on est
derrière les arts un vis à vis la cour
menti si vous étiez une arme l'humour un
supplice les lego de gens au casse et
chatou rire déjà tous les châteaux si
vous étiez un poison le sucre alors
ouais un dictateur un dictateur aura je
vais pas être original sûrement d'autres
l'ont dit mais enfin j'en vois qu'un c
c'est charlie chaplin
ouais personnes une infirmité timidité
ouais ça va la leur ils savent a su bien
un assassin j'ai été un assassin
ah oui dans les faits plusieurs fois non
dans des rêves mais parfois c'est très
curieuse j'aurais dû en parler un jour
un psy par les communes
j'ai souvent été un assassin qui
n'étaient pas pris je savais qu'il
savait que quelqu'un avait tué mais il
savait pas encore que c'était moi je
courais enfin ça doit être un truc de
culpabilité levé sentir là une torture
chatouille une humiliation gratos
tant qu'on est parti dans le très hard
si vous étiez une mort de rire droite
aïe
[Musique]
c'est bien même johnny rotten pourtant
c'est un battant c'est un roc
tu vois ma fille tu vois ma fille m'aime
génie rothen ne bouge pas ben guiga
antar évolution bien d'ailleurs je sors
j'ai dû quelques emails une fille qui
s'appelle patelin berthier qui me lie sa
révolution coûte cher à bafiba oui il
est toujours pas là fred b qui donc veut
faire son site sur les gens qui veulent
bouger des bassistes puis à quelques
opposants il ya un mec s'appelle vincent
vallières qui a viré sa fiancée clair
parce qu'elle bougeait pas remis d'une
gueule c'est fou mais qui vient leur
rendre
et il y en a d'autres comme mourad abbas
qui dit moi je doute je bouge pas
pendant jingle parce que toute façon je
suis bien au chaud sous ma couette et
alors oui il ya une fille qui dit elle
s'appelle floriane elle dit si j'enlève
un vêtement à chaque jing est ce que je
peux bouger
la réponse est oui dérogation spéciale
alors on va faire avec jenny rothen une
interview anti portrait chinois
daniel difficile à expliquer le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
qu'est ce que vous seriez comme fleurs
je serai un mieux autisme et l'anti
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
maladie donc johnny rotten if you were
10 is what kind of disease
would you be ce serait la peste parce
que je ressemble à un rat atteint par la
peste
si vous étiez une injure c'est une
injure ouais ça veut dire saisir que
daniel et c'est pas dans le traducteur
c'est un espèce de brigands daniel je
ferai du porno très bien daniel belinda
est peut-être plus rapidement si vous
étiez un accident je serai en ambulance
si vous étiez une guerre troisième
gardien si vous étiez un vis à vis
si vous étiez un supplice je pense que
d'une certaine manière musicalement je
le suis c'est bien si vous étiez une
cicatrice score cicatrices anales un
poison paysanne à la salmonelle j'aime
bien les salles prenait de fumée si vous
étiez un [ __ ] oui beaucoup dirais que
je suis déjà si vous étiez un assassin
n'y aurait pas de problème de gestion je
pense c'est tjrs un virus quelque chose
sur internet
elle a view à l'avenir j'ai vraiment si
la pitié
si vous étiez un dictateur je suis je
courais d'une certaine manière visible
un dictateur espagnol parce que ça
devient pire dictateur de mouches
espagnol moustiques espagnol si vous
étiez un terroriste mais je le suis avec
a demandé à la famille royale
britannique ils me connaissent très bien
et si vous étiez la mort quel genre de
mort seriez-vous d'euros ça c'est
quelque chose que je n'entends pas je
suis sourd tout d'un coup bravo
attention pareil moi parce qu'elle
récupère vous donner c'est le portrait
chinois
on va faire lentilles portrait chinois
de ventre et chinois oui si vous étiez
une fleur vite sur à mieux utiliser
l'anti portrait chinois de ses négatifs
donc si vous étiez un défaut vous sur
lesquels défaut l'égoïsme une injure
sympa une maladie le tétanos un accident
un crash d'avion une perversion les
câlins une guerre à dieffenthal une
guerre la guerre des boutons
un microbe la peste un vice le sucre un
dictateur amin dada une arme le fil
dentaire un supplice l'écartèlement une
cicatrice
les bleus à l'âme un poison
poison
un poison curare un [ __ ] dieu le père
hanna ça ça gilles de rais une torture
elle caresse une humiliation être
ignorée bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfait alors donc vous connaissez le
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
fleur je serai un myosotis ça c'est
l'anti sport très chic une rose c'est
pas ça du tout justement c'est si vous
étiez un défaut je serais très très
sympa et un petit peu chiante de vous et
ils ne jurent va te faire cuire un oeuf
pourri et mange le il me l'a vu la
pestouille à un accident je serai deux
autos tamponneuses qui se rentrent
dedans une perversion écoutez ce qui ne
me regarde pas une guerre je serai la
guerre des strings parce que je voudrais
ouvrir une guerre je suis contre les
strings abord vous et pour les tonga
préfère les tonga non je peux faire les
bons grosse leipp
[Rires]
lure explique parce que j'ai mené une
croisade ya cinq ans contre les caleçons
vous savez c'était ces gens de collants
avec le pied coupé et beaucoup de femmes
qui les portait donc j'étais à devenu un
peu la chef anti qu'elles sont enfin bon
maintenant c'est les strings qu'on voit
de plus en plus avec les beaux jours et
je trouve ça un peu curieux parce que le
principe du string c'est quand même que
ça ne se voit pas or ça se voit cg sur
le contre vous le tanga non plus non le
tanga dosettes tanga string ou slip ou
que son époux bon ça n'aille pas le
petit bateau le string parce que j'en
suis resté à une définition que carlos a
donné récemment aux grosses têtes dit
j'aime bien le string parce que ça
permet aux chats de jouer avec affichage
oui avait un dessin de wismes un affreux
vous n'êtes pas vu c'était une femme sur
la plage couché sur le ventre
il y avait un homme derrière elle avec
la bid coupé en deux dans le sens de la
longueur et elle lui elle se retourne à
lui dit si tu avais un peu plus patiente
[Rires]
on continue une arme deux doigts coupe
faim parce qu'après la plus fins du tout
un supplice bad obliger tout le monde à
mettre des strings vous aussi moi aussi
moi j'ai pas de moi je porte pas de slip
ben voilà autant de pas en mettre du
tout voilà moi g 8 g rien autant que je
peux pas vous le dire jean philippe le
sait vous gagnez du temps je m'habille
toujours pareil je mets pas de ce livre
très vite habillez vous étiez un poison
je serai une poison vous êtes le plus
grand si vous êtes une [ __ ]
alors j'aime pas du tout ce mot parce
que je trouve ça un mot qu'on emploie
quand enfin les hommes emploi quand ils
sont un peu à cours d'idées alors qu'un
salon on dit [ __ ] sonné c'était mignon
un seul homme c'est que c'est un
compliment pour les hommes
ah bon ah oui ben je prends pas comme ça
oui on le voit
vous figurez vous que je vais plus loin
que vous c'est un brevet de
qualification
donc j'attends du salat
alors string dessus tout ça sans trophée
bon je vous tienne assassin j'habiterai
21 oui ça normal une torture torture je
sais pas c'est une torture vous seriez
une interview de terreur distance est
entraîneur on rallume elodie qu'on bouge
froid pendant le jingle
bonne réponse de thierry ardisson bien
alors le portrait chinois ces sites
étaient une fleur je serai un mieux
autistes lentilles portrait chinois
celle inverse
si vous étiez un défaut je serai la plus
grande qualité de mon pire ennemi
ouais c'est pas mal ça si vous étiez une
rupture je ne peux pas être une rupture
j'ai trop vécu j'ai pas envie d'en
devenir une une injure si j'étais une
injure je serai fille de [ __ ] parce que
je suis pour la parité une maladie si
j'étais une maladie je crois que serait
la maladie d'alzheimer parce que je ne
pourrais pas me souvenir que j'ai la
maladie d'alzheimer
un accident de concorde comme ça je fais
la une de tous les journaux dans le
monde entier pendant un mois une
perversion une perversion ça c'est
difficile je crois que je serai la
zoophilie parce que j'ai jamais
rencontré une tortue d'eau ou un cochon
d'inde me refuser à 69 une guerre une
guerre bat une guerre lubrique c'est à
dire une guerre de position un vice si
j'étais un vice je serai un vice qui
englobe tous les autres vices et le sexe
parce que c'est en même temps un jeu de
hasard est une drogue
une trahison j'étais une trahison
je suis déjà une imposture jeu peut en
plus être une trahison une arme une arme
si j'étais une arme attendez laissez moi
un peu et une arme si j'étais une arme
je crois que serait la culture parce que
quand j'entends le mot revolver je sens
ma culture très bien un supplice le
supplice de la baignoire parce que j'ai
envie de mourir proprement une cicatrice
une cicatrice
le nombril du monde un poison et un
poison
alors là un poison qui coulerait dans
les veines de georges de boudu bouche un
[ __ ] tu t'es un [ __ ] serait un gros
[ __ ] comme ça je pourrais sortir une
grosse [ __ ] qui lui est si vous étiez
une [ __ ] jeté une [ __ ] sur une cape
une fille capable de coucher avec elle
moix ouais un impôt un impôt sur le
sex-appeal comme ça je serai exonéré
ouais une panne bas une panne
d'inspiration qui frapperait tous les
écrivains qui écrivent plus vite que moi
un dictateur
by clair il a écrit des best-sellers a
investi l'air ouais moi j'ai pas réussi
une infirmité une infirmité
michel petrucciani parce que j'adore le
jazz and haas à sa guise de bornes
parce qu'il a assassiné guy debord un
microbe un an ça me rendrait malade
d'être un microbe une plaie j'étais une
plaie je serai ouvertes toute la nuit
un fléau le sida parce que je suis très
people un terroriste je serai un
terroriste je préfère sauter des bombes
que les faire sauter pas mal une torture
une torture je serai l'avenir parce que
l'avenir appartient à ceux qui se lèvent
tôt et ça c'est une torture recevait
tous une humiliation une humiliation une
humiliation
je crois que je serai une soirée avec
rocco siffredi dans une boîte échangiste
est mort celle des autres travaux yann
moix a laissé un corps comme chez
grasset bon alors est-ce qu'on peut
baisser la lumière s'il vous plaît ça va
mieux cette lumière là c'est vrai bon je
pose la question aux 2 va raquer là le
plus rapide des deux d'accord vous avez
un portrait chinois
donc si tu étais une fleur qu'est-ce que
tu serais qu'est-ce que tu serais si tu
étais une fleur 3-1 myosotis à cause de
tes yeux
je sais pas c'est une seule une rose une
roue ville était une fleur une
marguerite gérard sol pour patrick
aujourd'hui non enfin sauf que c'est pas
vrai non pas la coiffure la vie et donc
c'est là que je suis on a dit prédit pas
le physique pas les cheveux par les
parents sauf que moi je parle pas de
fleurs j'ai dit si tu étais un [ __ ] du
srec et comme [ __ ] le salon de
l'agriculture
s'en sort du match était si tu étais un
défaut olivier oui bois caoutchouc et si
vous étiez une injure vous seriez quoi
comme un dur j'aime bien petite crotte
ça aussi oui moi je dis non je laisse
dans sa merde car si vous étiez une
maladie où seriez quoi comme maladie
l'engin de blanche moi mais c'est bien
la fièvre jaune la couleur un accident à
coup sûr patrick sébastien sanchez
semble apte en bas je voulais coupe
court où il met des trucs dessus pour
l'essai du team jean ce mec assez
s'allie à taper sa tête ça déboite et
qui s'est retrouvé comme ça moi un
sondage métro moi je suis concentré sur
le portail chinois
on m'a dit reste concentré oui si vous
étiez une perversion alors très très
bien justement j'étais une perversion
moi je veux dire vrai si on était une
vengeance est une malformation
si vous étiez une guerre la guerre de
cent ans je pense l'acier ça a duré
longtemps
c'était trop long on n'est pas de bonne
guerre pour briquet pour les laisser que
leur père est à l'enfer moi j'ai pas
tous les jours un dictateur le coiffeur
de patrick sébastien
[Applaudissements]
on a eu des mots avec lui si vous étés
un vice vous étiez à vis à vis à vis à
vis non non non service qui est 4 e
olivier là je suis à l'écart dans les
vieilles cannes qui dort elle qui a
redit moi je sais plus là moi je suis
leur aile
ok tu étais un supplice supplice être
obligé de regarder patrick sébastien
savez les cheveux on est sur un fil on
l'a réussi à faire parler de soi quand
c'est d'autres invités ont eu tôt fait
de la foule si vous étiez un poison à la
lace harbin lazardis tu regardes tu vas
voir baisser quasi et une affinité la
coiffure ardisson qui me connaît bien
il m'a dit la coiffure moi je veux non
mais moi je souhaite et je le dis je le
dis aux millions de gens qui nous
regardent
écrivez-nous soussan marotte quoi bon
dire que patrick garde sa cheville a
gardé toute façon mais oui pour moi ce
soir
non c'est pas ta crinière de lion c'est
joli c'est joli ça j'avais plus poétique
ça me faisait au moins deux queues de
cheval
il tient à sa naissance à la litter le
le coiffeur d'afrique cela si vous étiez
une humiliation
il va continuer moi ça me gêne pas ça va
vous laisser vous qua non
le boucle de patrick sébastien c'est
bien et si vous étiez un animateur télé
et ben voilà ça serait logique un
patrick sébastien pas toi quand tu es
une minute pour patrick sabatier si vous
c'est vrai que les bougies et tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir patrick j'en ai vu des pires
depuis
oui c'est ce que je vais dire la non pas
pourquoi ya pas patrick sabatier l'être
si j'étais à washington il dit mais
j'aurais dit linda redit comme ça
j'aurais pu me regarder dans une glace à
poil et me toucher les nichons non mais
c'est pas idiot dans ta raison car c'est
le mauvais temps moi je me disais qu a
fallu ctions attention linda vous les
connaissiez déjà lorsque l'on s'est
croisé mon chemin je crois si on rentre
et on amenait tu te souviens de paris
tafer palin dasté pop la serbie lundi
je suis comme ça même si on aura tout vu
mais cherche à un mètre dans cette ville
non oui l'on savoure est avec nous non
oui c'est la stupeur essais tous par
allumer la lumière s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez le portrait chinois non
je connais pas moi aussi le portrait
chinois c'est un jeu qui est vieux comme
on dit si vous étiez une fleur alors dit
surin myosotis tout mais l'anti portrait
chinois c'est autre chose
abu celle inverse n'a pas fini si vous
étiez à défaut vous seriez quoi comme
défaut à moi j'en sais rien encore mais
vous allez me reposer après justine
maladie enfin je serai la coqueluche fut
rien
si vous étiez un accident circulation si
vous étiez une perversion la pire
huitième guerre en dentelle un dictateur
papy nash est une arme de pacotille un
supplice chinois une cicatrice d'amour
si vous étiez un assassin landru parce
qu'il aimait les femmes
si vous étiez un [ __ ] vous pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup
bien si vous étiez un défaut un défaut
la curiosité est une perversion
peut-être mon papa si vous étiez une
arme une arme l'écriture un supplice
un supplice à un interrogatoire comme
celui-là la wii zijin cicatrice à
nombril un poison lent demi si vous
étiez une [ __ ]
en dehors de moi je vois pas une palme
ou panne
une panne d'ascenseur rempli de gens
hystériques un dictateur vous si vous
étiez l'infirmité voir la vie en rose un
assassin un antibiotique
si vous étiez une torture et une plume
légers t-il l'humiliation peut-être une
page blanche mais si vous étiez une mort
une mort ou rire quand je sauve la vie
de quelqu'un c'est bien bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bouche et les bouger je crois que
c'est oui je sais catherine mais je
crois que c'est le prénom
je crois qu'on n'y peut rien si tu veux
c'est un truc de laurent vité jamais
fait alors en faire lentilles portrait
chinois d'accord non alors par exemple
donc de vous dire si vous étiez une
fleur ou un poudrier a mis aux autistes
c'est un peu ridicule
je vais vous dire si vous étiez un
défaut un des shows wii ou la vache un
défaut j'hésite entre
mais jouer votre groupe vous avez vos
joues tu fais c'est une injure
une injure wattez jour croire et le cul
nordiste il m'a redit une maladie
l'amour à un accident un accident les
crottes de mon chien parce que j'ai un
chien depuis vigion richir oui alors il
s'appelle chocolat c'est ça non pas
chocolat il est chaud chocolat il
s'appelle rebelles un bon gros comme son
père ah c'est pas moi qui ai un revers
si vous étiez une perversion
si j'étais une conversion le ferait
votre questionnaire chez retirer de la
bande annonce une guerre une guerre
la prochaine ouais un vis à vis le sexe
laurent descamps lui dise ex aequo en
service sont obligatoires non trahison
trahison une trahison
le seul qui m'a le plus marqué ces
dernières années c'est celle de nicolas
sarkozy et d'edouard balladur voilà mais
voilà oui effectivement ils sont une
arme
si j'étais une arme je serai humour un
supplice un supplice clémence arnaud
[Applaudissements]
exagère pas mardi mais il vient tous les
samedis les derniers si vous étiez une
cicatrice une cicatrice l'arrêt du qu c
après si vous étiez un poison de tabac
une [ __ ]
linda hardy concert
[Musique]
la connaissance est croisée croiser ces
croisières d'affaires labrador un impôt
un impôt sur les grandes fortunes
moi je suis pour oui moi je me suis
jamais plaint de payer des sommes
exactement les gens gagnent de l'argent
en 2001 toute chasse et la correcte une
panne sexuelle
oui c'est la plus emmerdant tu veux dire
est que jamais leur chien mais à votre a
jamais jamais je suis tombé dans la
marmite du viagra crocheter le viagra
cette petite pilule bleue
l'acfo la m c'est des mecs qui bossent
les tester pour l'événement du jeudi
allez paris s'est fait à l'événement du
jeudi c'était lourd du journal et je
suis content qu'il est le cas vous avez
fait tester le viagra par bruno masure
jean pierre coffe laurent ruquier bon
voilà c'est alors ça vous fait rire
c'est bien sûr chaque mois vous savez
[Musique]
si vous étiez une torture une torture
clément s'annonçait bien les latics de
chez moi
si vous étiez une humiliation une nuit à
loaded
ouais le bdi a rien de pire vous êtes
sur scène ou même à la radio ou à la
télé vous croyez dire un truc de rouille
et s'est quant à elle rigole pas voilà
ça c'est une humiliation
1 ça vous arrive jamais si ça arrive
d'avoir tout le monde avant si vous
étiez une mort la petite mort en la
bouche là pendant le jingle
[Musique]
si vous étiez une injure je sais pas une
injure celle de l'âge une perversion la
virginité bravo une guerre rosell des
sexes une trahison
ben je sais pas le dentiste il vous dit
toujours que ça a pas fait remarquer
si vous étiez une arme l'humour un
supplice un supplice qu'on me demande de
me taire un poison et pokémon ah oui ok
mais si vous étiez une [ __ ] la mort un
dictateur mon chien ce qui peut placer
tous les jours un microbe
je dirais plutôt un parasite genre
acariens jour dans les lits c'est
agréable
un terroriste a terrorist l'image je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un guy
terrorisme pour moi les artistes les
gens qui font ce métier l'image est
toujours comme il faut plaire à qui on
doit plaire une espèce de dictature donc
je trouve extrêmement pénible et lourdes
voilà nous torturent une torture j'ai
pas être oubliés n'embauchent pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà je vous faire c'est le portrait
chinois vous connaissez le portrait
chinois chinois ces sites étaient une
fleur jeu sera un mot le myosotis si
j'étais un homme politique je serai
michel bulté tout ça moi je vous fais un
anti portrait chinois si vous étiez un
défaut vous seriez quoi comme défaut
elle va avoir beaucoup de difficulté 1
je sais pas
l'indécision ah oui voilà
si vous étiez une maladie une maladie se
serait forcément une maladie 201 oui tu
détiens dictateur ce serait une claire
forcément si vous étiez un avis la vertu
on aurait pensé et y est un supplice la
conversation
si vous étiez une humiliation si j'étais
une humiliation
ce serait victime qu'on me dise que je
fais une victime et une infirmité pour
finir je vous étiez une infirmité cas
l'infirmité sur vivo en bas je suis une
infirmière
[Musique]
super le bouge pas avant le jingle g20
si vous étiez donc si vous étiez une
injure vous serez heureux riez quoi
comme injures [ __ ] ciel [ __ ] ciel
s'est très si vous étiez une maladie le
syndrome d'alzheimer plate que tu
maladie que j'ai inventé dans un accord
au moins sur et j'aurais fait comme
creutzfeldt jacob ou non non non
si vous étiez un accident mon passage
dans cette émission
si vous étiez une perversion l'écriture
si vous étiez une guerre l'invasion du
japon par la belgique
si vous étiez un microbe la listeria
parce que depuis le temps la listeria
c'est moi si vous étiez un dictateur un
dictateur éclairé avis le vinaigre une
arme
la fourche est un supplice la gourmette
ses propos m gourmette
oui quand sa porte et une gourmette oui
si vous étiez une panne ben là j'ai une
panne quoi si vous étiez une cicatrice
celle que j'ai là si vous étiez une
[ __ ]
l'une des 343 si vous étiez un poison
le mercure une torture le saumon une
humiliation
le serre-tête un assassin mois un
détritus ce que je mange
si vous étiez une chanteuse en mai
robert roberval univers vous connaissez
le portrait chinois
elle est très inquiète et je la sors pas
souvent la petite d'ailleurs j'ai
remarqué qu'elle ne sorte qu'avec
vouloir mais on ne la voit jamais sera
plateaux télé on jamais on attend je
suis très fier et très heureux de
l'avoir donc fait gentil avec lui très
gentil jusqu'ici ça va la province jeudi
qu'elle était bien foutu qu'elle jouait
bien tout va bien la bon alors vous
connaissez le portrait chinois donc ces
sites étaient une fleur lentilles
portrait chinois évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus négatif que ça si vous
étiez et vous dites je saurai si vous
étiez un comique pas drôle mais je
serais moi quand je suis dans des
émissions télé une tout le monde attend
que ce le soit voilà si peu comme tous
les comics ouais un peu
mine de rien une analyse que partage
votre réponse si vous étiez un animal
malodorant alors là mon chien a connu un
sûr mais après son 100 points et plus
encore
[Musique]
il s'appelle comment elle s'appelle
fivete fécondation in vitro et
transporte passé embryonnaire la
silhouette si vous étiez une émission de
tf1 restaurerait la mire si vous étiez
une maladie honteuse
une alopécie brutal se perdrait tous mes
poils fred chaumet nous resterait que
mon défaut de rendement de cheveu sur la
langue
[Rires]
si vous étiez une manière de mourir bas
plutôt que mourir dans un dernier soupir
je mourrai dans un dernier soupir ans si
vous étiez un fardeau pour vos proches
c'est pas de proches
si vous étiez un film qui fait pleurer
alors là sans hésitation vercingétorix
et christophe lambert
on est d'accord
un médicament un cachet un gros cachet
le yak ici j'en ai pas
[Rires]
pour les écrire les pièces si vous étiez
un crime un ice cream war si vous étiez
une partie du corps pas indispensable
double menton si vous étiez une coiffure
raté a su rien vu je rigolais une
choucroute j'arrête une voiture
française une ds alors c'est comment
vous répandez en gros pourquoi anti
portrait à importer chinoise s'est par
exemple si vous étiez une fleur à vous
dites je serai un mieux lotis sous un
oeil et un anti plantes les chinois
c'est plutôt si vous étiez une merde
d'accord voilà c'est ma si j'étais une
merde pour elle pense tu serais qui
j'étais une merde
non je peux pas répondre ce que la
personne est ici ça se comprend
[Musique]
tu peux préciser que c'est pas bruno que
sinon bastien fait c'est pas de
magouilles
alors si vous étiez un groupe comique
pas drôle vous seriez qui les robins des
bois al qaïda le gie vite
ah si vous étiez un mauvais prétexte
manger des éclairs sous prétexte qu'il
fait pas beau merci marc rennard d'être
toujours à mes côtés
si vous étiez une partie du corps dont
on peut se passer
moi j'aurais dit mme poitrine opulente
way des cheveux si vous étiez mauvaise
nouvelle elise maples au tgv qui n'a
rien à dire sylvain moi moi la pire
mauvaise nouvelle qu'on pourrait me dire
c'est en fait il faudrait que tu
refasses tout du cp à la terminale
recevoir ce serait aux radiologues et
moi du cpa maternelle si vous étiez un
faux numéro
les 34 pourquoi ils disent que c'est
intéressant si vous étiez un produit
ménager un démêlant pour chatte
nager ça non mais ici si vous étiez un
motif de suicide
moi moi si on me dit tu vas mourir dans
deux minutes je me suicide ah ouais
ouais c'est pour ça si vous étiez une
femme de président hillary clinton à 20
ans un monstre à mes roues oui j'ai
envie de coucher avec aucun des
présidents que je connais je suis sûr et
c'est des mecs contre des ego je suis
tellement surdimensionné que c'est
forcément tu as us et des ministres et
lisent jamais si vous étiez une forme
fall et égalise un pénis ou balancer
élise fois pour lui donne la parole à
une forme phallique bah oui un pénis
bah oui quand même la fonte panique la
boue la plus de la retire non la tête de
maurice
et loire vous étiez un pays en guerre
monaco j'ai pas lu le journal de points
si vous étiez un fardeau pour les autres
on dit pas aux ford ont dit infernale
vous étiez une émission de télé on ne
peut pas plaire à tout le monde
présentée par thierry ardisson
ouais c'est hier si vous étiez à défaut
de prononciation attends moi je serai
maurice crible y a des mots très simples
qu'est ce que tu attends des mots très
simples et qu'il a des raisonnements qui
dit au théâtre par exemple c'est très
difficile de dire pour mon boulot
essayer très très sérieux il à dd c'est
sur des mots il n'y arrive pas c'est
vrai je n'arrive pas à dire pour c'est
vrai dans les décolletés n'arrive pas
oui
poumon explique grâce à des as dans la
rivière année
[Musique]
et élan alors axelle red ou connaissez
le ventre et chinois si vous êtes une
fleur je serai un myosotis bien là c'est
l'anti portrait chinois si vous étiez
une maladie je serai un rhume une drogue
je serai la cocaïne
parce que j'ai fait une chanson sur mon
album qui s'appelle blanche neige ouais
trop blanche neige et j'ai comparé la
cocaïne à une femme par lequel on est
obsédé à ce revirement serait obsédé par
moi
si vous étiez un bruit si vous étiez une
faute de goût je serai moi même pas
pourquoi mais je sais pas j'ai dit ma
soeur m'a toujours dit que j'avais
jamais mauvais goût parce que je porte
les choses qu'ont les gens comprennent
pas encore à leur menu dont elle attend
un peu de temps et moi je vais vous dire
un truc qui tue pas pu prendre un pain
de philippe val
en sortant je trouve de plus en plus
sexy moi je confirme là ce soir reste
bouche bée
on l'a secouru je trouve qu'on a connus
accélérait dès l'été elle était bébé
mais là elle devient femme quoi vraiment
bien si vous étiez une façon de mourir
mourir de rire
ouais une insulte discours une allergie
elle y une allergie
un mur otis si vous étiez une question
qui vous ferait quitter ce plateau ça
serait quelle question
j'ai été poli de rester s'il était
arnaud je leur ai dit que j'allais faire
ce serait plus normal en même temps avec
ce qu'il boit il puise souvent si vous
étiez une arme le regard qui tue à une
perversion sexuelle congénères si vous
étiez une teinture rater si vous regarde
axelle red si vous étiez une blague
belge
vous savez ce qui m'ennuie les français
c'est que j'aime pas raconter les
blagues au front serait un parce que
d'habitude il faut leur a compté deux
fois
[Applaudissements]
c'est une mauvaise critique ce qu'ils
m'ont dit qu'ils me feraient encore le
plus mal c'est de dire qu'il n'ya pas de
mélodie
si vous étiez un surnom qui fâchent
j'aimerais tu as ta place moi j'aurai un
pour vous oui
jane a autorisé le principe le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
l'antique entre échinacées si vous étiez
un [ __ ] qui seriez vous moi dubois
ouais gomez
si vous étiez une infirmité
l'impuissance
pas mûres si vous étiez une drogue douce
si vous étiez un super pouvoir lire dans
les pensées pour les interrogatoires ça
peut servir
le viagra ouais vous étiez une guerre
guerre des nerfs si vous étiez une femme
femme à poigne
margaret thatcher si vous étiez une
façon de mourir la pendaison
parce qu'après ça fait paintball si vous
étiez une insulte îlotiers si vous étiez
une arme un flash ball
si vous étiez une perversion sexuelle
moi si vous étiez une opération
chirurgicale la guerre en irak
je vous étiez une mauvaise nouvelle
coupable
si vous étiez un film raté voilà le
gendarme et les gendarmettes pas mieux
si vous étiez un mauvais rappeur
eh ben florange si vous étiez un très
mauvais rappeur faf larage si vous étiez
à pêcher l'avarice la convoitise et toi
te fare la gourmandise on va faire
l'anti portrait chinois chaud
[Musique]
alors bénédicte si vous étiez un pays
chaud je serai la guadeloupe
ouais mais la thaïlande vous êtes
originaire de là-bas ouais ouais
si vous étiez un film chaud emmanuel
c'est bien emmanuel moi ça va beaucoup
marc emmanuel quand j'ai vu manuel ma
sexualité a changé grossemy si vous êtes
une boisson chaude un chocolat chaud
vous étiez une mer chaude maintiennent
je retire on voit les affaires on a dit
pardon alors voilà mer de caraïbes
ouais tu sais tu vas pour les caraïbes
si vous êtes une confidence chaude
[Musique]
et
une amie qui me qui me jetterai dans
l'oreille sa première fellation si vous
étiez un vent chaud le sirocco
souhaitiez une époque chaude 69
si vous étiez un plat chaud brandade de
morue
si vous étiez un mec chaud et bien
comment il est alors très beau très beau
il a un métier tout ça va une amie il
est lâché son fils avec qui n'est hélas
pas quel bois il vient pas parce que
c'est un métier que moi comment il
s'appelle benjamin benjamin flament
didon si vous étiez un souvenir chaude
parce que dans mon bouquin si vous étiez
un objet chaud mon scooter
si vous étiez un artichaut hardy chaud
[Musique]
benjamins
est ce qu'on a mais l'unami chrome en
benjamins tenez benjamin attention à
belhadj ans et très bien donc benjamin
c'est vous donc l'homme show de notre
ami bénédicte martin ça doit pas être
facile tous les jours une vendays comme
ça la maison fait comme angoisse il ya
un traducteur en région benjamin sérieux
comment vous faites c'est un sacré
pistolet quand même c'est impossible
c'est à dire que je suis obligé de me
battre toutes les 5 secondes avec des
gens ouais
heureusement je suis assez musclé donc
je me défends comme je te vois venir
qu'après un bouquin comme ça beaucoup de
mecs vont se jeter sur elle en imaginant
qu'elle est chaude en sachant qu'elle
est chaud
[Musique]
l'ex fiancé c'était c'était éric si vous
étiez une injure vous soyez quelle
injure connard une maladie une maladie
orpheline plus quitte à être on a là
d'autant que ce soit tout seul une
perversion une perversion la fidélité
une trahison trahison la vieillesse une
arme le silence un supplice
l'adolescence un poison le champagne une
panne
une panne de magnétoscope quand on
enregistre un fim qui ne passe qu'une
fois qu'on a vu un dictateur un nouveau
né si vous étiez une torture soyons
littéraire les la lecture des oeuvres
complètes de christine angot ou là une
mort
l'ivresse pour être ivre mort une plaie
une plaie d'argent
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui les andes
l'histoire de frank c'est publié chez
fayard mais l'amnésie
philippe geluck si vous étiez une injure
vous seriez quoi une injure mais nommé
nouveau souffle et pas à bordel de merde
fait chier [ __ ] de ta mère de mes deux
matches et y ait une même avis la civic
hull je savais ce que c'est ah non c'est
une maladie génétique rare
ouais c'est les gens qui au lieu d'avoir
la raie des fesses verticale ou
horizontale
non mais attendez déco n'est pas parce
que c'est grave parce que si vous
glissez par exemple sur une rampe
d'escalier en qu'hilton ex est normal ça
fait si vous souffrez cilic hull ça fait
du bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un accident cardio vasculaire un vice
vice président des états unis dont le
président est jean avis en lui-même
d'ampleur un supplice suppositoire la
téléréalité attach épices du pal pour un
chat qui a pas passé si vous étiez une
cicatrice j'ai la très bonne maîtrise du
pal pour un shérif c'est là d'une
cicatrice je pense que tu peux partir
merci non mais rejetant pays tient une
ci dessus l'aurore et voilà vous étiez
vous étiez une cicatrice là une
cicatrice au monsieur un jour ouvert le
bras comme ça et ma femme était ce
jour-là enceinte de huit mois et demi
nue on était à l'étranger en
tchécoslovaquie on est arrivé à
l'hôpital
ils ont cru que celles qui venaient pour
accoucher ils l'ont emmené
et moi je suis restée là le figuier dans
la salle d'attenté c'est vrai avant
qu'elle puisse leur expliquer en
tchécoslovaquie
c'était pour moi qui perdent et mon sens
voilà si vous étiez un poison le hareng
la maladie un poisson un poison mais
beaucoup de harengs ça peu intoxiquées
finalement ça comme le foie gras mais
mais délègue bien j'en parle plus une
infirmité vous
si vous étiez nasa ça alors là
franchement le deuxième tireur de kenny
parce qu'au moins je saurai si vous
étiez une p la télé réalité
si vous étiez une torture de la télé
réalité
si vous étiez une humiliation perdre
dans un truc de télé réalité vous étiez
aucun terroriste nikos aliagas attention
si vous étiez un défaut marina vous
seriez quoi la radinerie way et toi
jusqu'à de marina pour venger de ce que
vous avez dit que vous étiez une injure
zut
va te faire cuire le q si vous étiez une
maladie juste un toc troubles
obsessionnels le travail salon j'écris
la turquie est une pièce qui sera
produite bientôt les prochaines est
alors de nous la meilleure vannes pour
voir ça commençait de vrai qu'il y ait
pour les répliques s'étaler tout au
faire [ __ ] ouais c'est bien je
tâtonne jeunes dans belleville syndrome
gilles de la tourette dont le c'est
normal qu'ils disent
si vous étiez une maladie ou un petit
rhume mais avec plein de morgue
voilà c'est exactement ce que j'allais
dire que vous étiez un accident alors
moi je serais un accident très idiot qui
est arrivé pour de vrai à la mère d'un
ami elle s'est auto écrasé avec sa
voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle était dans un
parking de son parking lac était en
pente et elle a oublié le frein à main
est sorti pour prendre un truc paf le
pied s'est coincé et attendait c'était
très grave parce qu'on a dû lui ôter les
deux poumons tous les ans je veux dire
meriem si vous étiez une perversion
marina est vieillot philly si vous étiez
une perversion je serai
ce que vous m'avez proposé de faire en
coulisses tout cuvée soutien disent une
boule en 2015 c'est une trahison aller
chez fogiel une trahison ben je balance
risque que vous m'avez proposé de faire
en colis si vous étiez un poison à la
cigarette
j'aime trop c'est bien bien là bravo
bravo la nicotine bravo moi j'y serai un
poisson rouge
[Rires]
si vous étiez une panne beaucoup non
mais oh ça va on a droit d'être très
grossier sur bande et moi je demande
tout le temps oh là là pour moi j'y
serai une panne d'électricité pendant la
finale de la coupe du monde voilà tu la
rente dit alors moi aussi parce qu'après
ce que j'ai rajouté l'aller boubakary
qu'il appelait depuis un moment à
l'interné décrit trois vannes si vous
étiez une infirmité élise larnicol du
hamas à quelqu'un qui fera un crime
parfait
d'ailleurs je sais ce que c'est que le
crime parfait j'ai réfléchi c'est un
crime gratuit
parce que si c'est un acte gratuit c'est
impossible on se retrouve alors ce soir
marina donner des bons conseils fumée
crime gratuit parfait si vous étiez une
mort pas définitive si vous étiez à
microbes
un microbe de ahmed 80
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci serge même si tu trouves que je
suis mal habillé merci quoi il a dit que
c'était ma mamie d'habitude et le public
ne sait pas que serge khalfon s'habille
exclusivement en prada donc forcément
quand tu vois un tee shirt il ay l'adc
l'opérateur le mieux habillé de paris
sans même qu'un réalisateur mannequin
gens l'appellent réalisateur vainqueur
absolument que tu es bon bah c'est entre
nous tu vois serge tout le monde le sait
en tentant pas n'est pas d'échangé dans
la journée casse toi ma belle tu es prêt
pour l'entier portrait chinois
[Applaudissements]
djamel ça soit une heure y'a pas de
couilles y reviendra plus à une heure je
suis désolé je voulais pas le faire au
départ ma part je le fais dissidente et
portrait chinois d'accord joey starr
mais là quand même pour l'autre
tu voyais pas les pitas leur ce qu'ils
faisaient merci il disait des blagues
racistes
ça fait trois jours qu'il cherche
juliette elle m'a dit [ __ ] c'est
dégueulasse
j'avais lutté près ça va heureusement
medicine mais la vie djamel un beau être
venu avec une armée de [ __ ] ils ne
manquent pas lorsqu'il fait il fait
début des petits traits métadonnées du
marché a un peu la gueule c'est pas
grave c'est juste muriel que je voulais
pas visé j'en ai pris un peu monsieur la
compassion opposition et oriane et on
peut tout faire maintenant tu bouges
piano
brossollet vous pouvez maintenant jeu
mais est ce que tu sais que tu es
chaussure droite c'est fait exprès ou
tablier l'étiquette les tickets ça
s'appelle le style ça s'appelle du vol
jamais tu sais que des parents muriel il
vend des chaussures donc aller au tour
bond des prêts ouais si c'était un gros
mot attends je vais juste vérifier un
truc quand un pape et le pinard à ces
mecs de banlieue c'était orange
marcheurs
[Applaudissements]
je suis
les relais le match devient j'étais trop
vite et c'est très bien vas-y tu t'étais
un gros mot sa mère lipopette c'était
une guerre une guerre si j'étais une
guerre voilà un coup je serai la guerre
contre les pointes sèches et les cheveux
cassants
[Applaudissements]
c'était un accident
la coupe du monde regarde la dernière
coupe du monde c'était un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur charlie chaplin
j'étais un bruit j'étais un gorille le
bruit qui court que je suis régulier de
billups
[Applaudissements]
je sais par mois après l'émission de m6
des terrasses à zinedine zidane sans
exception tu es d une trahison
mon bras droit ces [ __ ] n'écoute pas
confiance à c'était un meuble un canapé
convertible pour le convertir à l'islam
qu'ils étaient un supplice voté chirac
en 2002 ça c'est un supplice c'était un
légume chirac le site était très peur
j'ai fait un terroriste carlos papayou
papayou l'aîné c'était un saint maclou
pour les moquettes
au mont saint michel pour lui rien s'il
était un supplice je recommence
si j'étais un supplice reste gros coup
[Applaudissements]
ça inquiète dit le maire cette mousse
c'est incroyable qu'ils tuent pas envie
de te taper devant tout le monde tu fais
dire c'est quoi toi tu rigoles comme un
conte de ses blagues c'est pour ça qu'il
y va aussi après dernier
je suis surenchérit arrêts en plus j'ai
du white spirit
je garde un regard du feu mais sans s'en
gardent pas qu'est ce que c'est ça je
peux je peux mais je ne peux pas rester
comme ça c'est pas possible il est calme
trop dans ton sur ton plateau plus ça y
est j'ai attrapé la crève bâtiment tôt
pour déjà mais pas une petite culotte
pour joey starr
petite écharpe
vas-y vas-y pardon si tu étais un animal
mon frère mon bonheur de monde apple
n'arrive pas tu sais pourquoi parce que
gillett avait pas beaucoup dormi si tu
étais un impôt mon père et si c'était
une ordure à le père noël ouais tu m'as
il m'a oublié - dernière rien ramené
j'ai commandé un astra 2c pc 4
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible